ce 28 juin devait être un jour de fête
le neuvième anniversaire d'un petit
garçon plein de vie
ce fut le jour de la confirmation d'un
cauchemar les corps carbonisé découvert
lundi à ville parfois sont bien ceux
d'hervé delaunay et de son fils le petit
garçon était l'oeuvre avant la crémation
on a constaté l autopsie de plus au
niveau du cac mais on voudrait qu'ils
pourraient être compatibles avec des
coups de couteau détails sordides sur la
chronique d'un drame annoncé plusieurs
jours avant ce geste désespéré du père
commis à l'heure même où son fils de va
lui être retiré son avocate avait
interpellé les magistrats du tribunal de
vesoul et tout particulièrement la juge
des enfants
elle y décrivait un homme détruit par la
cruauté d'une institution inhumaine
lorsqu'un avocat parle d'une issue
tragique a minima le magistrat ce droit
d'appeler la bocca pour comprendre un
tel terme et prendre les mesures
nécessaires les magistrats ne sont pas
au dessus des lois
ils doivent répondre de leurs actes
comme n'importe quel citoyen il en va de
même d'un éducateur d'un service social
qui dépendent tous de l'état pour le
parquet le système a fonctionné c'est
l'avocate qui a failli elle aurait dû
s'y perd il y avait déposé un référé
d'urgence près la cour d'appel
or la cour d'appel était déjà saisie
elle devait statuer en septembre pour
autant les magistrats vésulien avait
refusé de reporter le placement de
l'enfant
tout comme il avait refusé qu'il passe
son anniversaire en famille ce dossier
n'est pas un dossier polémique par
rapport au suivi qu'elle fait
l'institution judiciaire le suivi
également effet le conseil départemental
sur quatre ans quasiment sur trois ans
et demi
je crois que ces drames le drame d'une
tension familiale extrêmement intense
une tension encore une fois qui conduit
un père tué son enfant
je crois qu'ils confirment
malheureusement l'urgence qu'il y avait
à prendre une mesure la famille du père
n'entend pas en rester là qui devrait
engager une action en responsabilité de
l'état et porter plainte contre la juge
des enfants et les éducateurs en charge
de la faire